[Music]
they're smooth like butter and pull in
las vegas in like no other
good job all right the k-pop group bts
performs the first of four concerts at
the legion stadium tomorrow night now
take a look here this is a live picture
from the stadium where hopefully we can
get the shot right there there you go
all right so there's a couple of folks
that are still making their way over to
that exclusive area for to get all their
gear for the concert and all the craze
began before sunrise you never really
expect what is ever going to happen
especially with like bts like their
music like what they produce
bts fever continues to sweep around the
globe and las vegas is no exception the
k-pop group taking over the town with
four sold-out concerts and their fan
base known as bts army can't get enough
i've been wanting this blanket literally
for like ever so finally got it because
it sells out super quickly and then i
also got this hoodie julie and her
friends are from out of town they rushed
to allegiant stadium for official
merchandise sales at two in the morning
along with thousands more the fans are
collectors we like to collect
various items t-shirts jackets
especially exclusive items melody lee is
a las vegas resident and part of the
local bts army but good luck finding her
this week she's hitting all the themed
pop-up spots on and off the strip over
the course of several days i went to the
photo exhibit already fantastic they it
was basically like a museum of all of
their photos from their concerts i also
went to the pop-up shop which was
amazing it was very interactive fans
spending hundreds and even thousands of
dollars on merchandise on top of the
concert hotel and travel expenses which
they say is all worth it honestly having
like the time of your life because
that's exactly what they want from you
is to have like the time of your life
and just to go out there and like make
the most of everything that you can do
all right tonight las vegas will be
welcoming bts and their army of fans
with a city-wide marquee takeover now
for one night only several marquis along
the strip will shine purple which is the
group's color representation of love oh
even the bellagio getting in on all this
action right with a new fountain show
celebrating the group's hits butter and
dynamite bts members got a sneak peek
earlier this week but it officially
launches tonight at 8 and will run on
rotation this weekend as well as next
woohoo